كلنا نعرف تاريخ العلاقات المتوتره بين
الصين وامريكا واللي زادت من عهد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب واستمرت
لغايه عهد الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن من كم
يوم كانت الاخبار كلها بتتكلم عن تقارب
يعني كان يذوب لسه راح يصير لما تم
الاعلان عن زياره لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
للصين وحتى اخبار كمان عن انه كان راح
يقابل الرئيس الصيني كمان في الزياره هذه
لكن كل هذه الاخبار والامال تبخرت من بعد
الملحمه اللي صارت واللي مغطيه على اي
اخبار ثانيه حول العالم طبعا بنتكلم عن
دراما منطاد التجسس الصيني فاللي صار انه
السلطات الامريكيه اعلنت الخميس عن رصد
منطاد صيني فوق اراضيها وهذا الاعلان جاء
من بعد ما مواطنين شافوه فوق مونتانا وهذه
منطقه فيها قواعد عسكريه حساسه
ومستودعات الصواريخ نوويه تحت الارض
السلطات الامريكيه طلعت بعد بلاغات
المواطنين عارفه بوجود المنطاد وانه رصد
اول مره فوق الاسكا في 28 يناير ويتحرك
ودخل كندا في 30 الشهر ورجع المجال
الامريكي في واحد وتلاتين الشهر طيب ليه
ما اسقطون السلطات الامريكيه بتقول انه من
وقت مرصدته وهو ما رجع للمياه المفتوحه
وانه خافت تسقطه او تتعامل معه فوق مناطق
سكنيه المنطاد اللي بنتكلم عنه حجمه بحجم
ثلاثه حافلات يعني مدرسيه الصين طلعت
بعدها واعترفت انه المنطاد منطاتها لكن
قالت انه مو عسكري بالاداء مدنيه
بيستخدموا لابحاث الارصاد الجويه وانه
انحرف عن مساره بسبب رياح غريبه واعتذرت
لامريكا عن انتهاك المنطاد للاجوائها لكن
هذه الروايه ما اقنعت امريكا لمصر انه
المنطاد هو المنطاد تجسس وبدانا نشوف
تصريحات اخذ ورد وتاكيد وتكذيب الصين مصره
على كلامها وبتطالب امريكا بالهدوء وعدم
المبالغه فرد الفعل مصره على روايتها وامر
بايدن باسقاط المنطاد كمان وتم اسقاطه
بالفعل يوم السبت فوق مياه المحيط الاطلسي
في عمليه شاركت فيها عده طائرات
ومن بعد ما اسقطت واشنطن المنطاد طلع
بايدن ووجه التحيه للطيارين اللي اسقطوه
وقال انه هو امر او هو امر باسقاطه من يوم
الاربعاء وسبب التاخير الخوف على الناس
[موسيقى]
طلع اعلن انه حيجمع حطام المنطاد عشان
يعرفوا المعلومات اللي الصين جماعتها
الصين عصبت وطلعت ادانت واستنكرت التصرف
الامريكي باسقاط المنطاد وقالت انه كان رد
فعل مبالغ فيه وانه امريكا انتهت القوانين
الدوليه وانها بتحفظ بحق الرد وطلعت بعدها
من ساعات واعلنت اقاله مسؤول الارصاد
الجويه بسبب المنطاد الصيني وحملته
مسؤوليه الخطا اللي صار في تغيير مسار
المنطاد واختراقه للاجواء الامريكيه القصه
عامله طبعا ابعاد واخذ ورد واسئله
واستفسارات على كل الاصابع اولا داخل
امريكا في غضب خاصه من قبل الجمهوريين
اللي بيعتبروا اللي بيعتبروا اللي صار
اخفاق لاداره بايدن في حمايه الامن القومي
وشايفين كمان انه اداره بايدن عارفه من
زمان عن المنطاد وخبط الموضوع علشان ما
تبين اخفاقها هذا في المقابل طبعا تم
الاعلان عن الغاء زياره بلنكن اللي كانت
مقرره للصين وطلعت فجاه الصين وقالت ما في
زي اصلا اعلنا عنها وامريكا تعلن براحتها
فهنا صار في تساؤلات هل مثلا في علاقه بين
القص اللي صارت هذه وبين الزياره هل هي
محاوله لالغائها مثلا من احد الطرفين او
طرف ثالث وفي طبعا السؤال الاكبر التاني
اللي هو روايه مين هي الصحيحه يعني الصين
بتقول منطاد بحثي وهذه يعني روايه تتصدق
لانه ليه مثلا ممكن الصين تتجسس بمنطاد
عند اقمار صناعيه كمان كثيره هذا غير
امريكا بنفسها اعترفت على لسان مسؤول انه
سبق ورصدت مناطيد صينيه فوق امريكا اكثر
من مره في السنوات الماضيه وما عملت شيء
امريكا وقتها في الوقت نفسه في تحليلات
تانيه بتقول لا ممكن يكون للتجسس وتكون
الصين بتتجسس باقمار صناعيه
وبمناطيد كمان طيب غير كل هذا فكره اسقاط
المنطاد او فكره اسقاط امريكا لمنطقه صيني
واللي بالمناسبه هي اول حادثه اسقاط
للقوات الامريكيه لاي مركبه اجنبيه من وقت
الحرب العالميه الثانيه حادثه مثل هذه لاي
درجه خطيره وايش سبب خط هذه الاسئله راح
يجاوبنا عليها الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور احمد عجاج اهلا فيك معنا دكتور احمد
او الشيخ خلينا نبدا بالروايات المتعدده
والتحليلات اللي ماليه كل مكان يعني لو
تدخل على تويتر كل شخص جالس بحلله عنده
راي في الموضوع حضرتك
بخبرتك اجت الروايه التي تتوقع انها هي
الاصح
طبعا اذا كان يعني المنطاد هو للتجسس ام
لا او انه مجرد الاعصاب لا احد سيعرف الا
اذا تمكن الامريكيون من انتشال حطام
المنطاد لكني دعني يعني اعقد مقارنه بين
ذلك ان هناك حرب معلومات بين الصين وبين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحرب تجسس
قويه والمعلومات هي العنصر الاهم في
الانتصار في اي معركه ممكنه لذلك انا
اعتقد ان يمكننا ان نقارن بينما حدث مع
ابناء الاتحاد السوفيتي وامريكا عندما
ارسلت امريكا طائره لا يمكن اكتشافها
واسقطها الروس وعندما اسقطوها الروس قال
الامريكان انها مجرد الارصاد وللابحاث
وليست للتجسس لكن الروس امسكوا بالقائد
واظهروه على التلفاز واعترف بانه كان
يتجسس وعند ذلك اعترفت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه المنطاد ليس لديه يعني قائد
ليقوده لانه يتحرك بنفسه ولا يمكننا ان
نعرف لكن حطامه سيعطينا فرصه لنعرف ان كان
التجسس ام لا لكن دعيني اقول لك ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه منذ 2020 وهي
تطور تكنولوجيا المناطيد لانها رخيصه جدا
وتبقى في الفضاء لمده اشهر يعني دون ان
احد يعني يعتبر انها للتجسس لانها مناطيد
وبالتالي اسقاطها صعب جدا ايضا لان كما
رايتم في عرضتم في برنامجكم انها قد تؤذي
المواطنين لان عند اسقاطها تنبعث منها
غازات وحيطان وهي كبيره جدا لذلك المناطيل
هي حرب المستقبل القادمه لانها رخيصه
وتختلف عن الاقمار الصناعيه بكثير لان
الاقمار الصناعيه تمشي في مسار معين ويمكن
تتبعه اما المناطيط فقط تطورت مؤخرا لدرجه
انها بالحساب الرقمي يمكن ان تسير وفق
حركه الرياح فاذا كانت تريد ان تنزل الى
اسفل فانها تعد برمجه وتراقب حركه الرياح
وتسير في الطريق التي تريدها القوى التي
تحركها لذلك اعتقد الان لا يمكننا الجزم
بانها يعني تجسس وان كنت اميل الى ذلك لكن
لننتظر الحيطان طيب واسقاط امريكا لها
وغضب الصين من ذلك هل تعتقد انه حيكون له
تداعيات كبيره
طبعا الصين يعني كما تعرفي عندما لا طبعا
لن يكون له تداعيات لان الاسقاط تم في
اراضي امريكيه وهو اعتداء على السياده
الامريكيه وحتى الصينيون قالوا انهم يعني
لم يكونوا يقصدون ذلك وانما حدث خطا لكن
اسقاطه واسقاط ايضا للهيبه الصينيه يعني
هي من ناحيه معنويه لا اكثر ولا اقل ولكن
تداعيات الاسقاط هي مهمه جدا لان هناك نوع
من الانفراج الان بين الصين والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وزياره بلينكن كانت
يعني مرحله انفتاح لانه لم يزر يعني احد
الصين منذ عام 2018 وياتي هذا المنطاد في
هذه اللحظه بالذات وعكر العلاقات وبالتالي
قطع بلينك زيارته للصين لكن دعيني اقول ان
قطع هذه الزياره او عدم اتمامها ليس
معناها انه لا يريد ان يتباحث مع الصين
انما لا يريد ان تكون زيارته كلها حول
البالون لانه اذا ذهب الان فكل الصحافي
يتحدثون عن البالون واسبابه وما وراءه
لذلك اعتقد انه اخرها لوقت اخر
تعتقد انه في اي احد من مصلحته كانت انه
مثلا يخرب هذه الزياره فاشتغل على هذا
الموضوع
طبعا طبعا يعني هناك في القياده الصينيه
العسكر والاجهزه الامنيه تحصل على ميزينات
ضخمه جدا ولا تريد اي يعني انفراج في
العلاقات لان اي انفراج في العلاقات سيؤدي
الى التوصل الى اتفقيات تقلص من التسابق
في التسلح وبالتالي التخلص ميزانيات
العسكر ولذلك قد يكون هناك يعني اجهزه
داخل الجيش الروسي الاجهزه الامنيه ارسلت
هذا المنطاد وقد لا يكون قد يكون بالخطا
لذلك كل هذا لا يمكن ان نعرفه الا لاحقا
عندما تتكشف اخبار كثيره لكن احتمال واسع
ان هناك يعني عناصر او اجنحه في القياده
الصينيه تريد تخريب هذه العلاقه وعدم حصول
اي انفراج وكذلك في امريكا كما ذكرتم ان
هناك جمهوريون يلومون الرئيس بيدا على
تهاونه ابن الصين مع انه تشدد اكثر من
ترامب في علاقاته مع الصين لكن السياسه
تلعب دورها في هذا المجال ولكن من الناحيه
الامريكيه كمان هل تعتقد انه مثلا يعني
كمان كانت في زي ما يقولوا ضغوطات علشان
برضو هذه الزياره ما تتم مش بس حتى من
الجمهوريين يعني من داخل الاداره ايضا كما
تحدثت انه مثلا من داخل الاداره الصينيه
طبعا يعني هناك يعني
صناعات ضخمه هائله وتحصل على الملايين
المليارات من الحكومه الامريكيه وقد تتضرر
هي الاخرى ايضا لذلك قد يكون لها مصلحه
ايضا في ذلك لكن بالنهايه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نعرف ان القرار شفاف
ويمكننا ان نعرف ماذا تتحدث عن الموضوع
لايام دكتور احمد هذا اللي زاد الشكوك نعم
نعم
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعترفت انها ليست
المره الاولى التي يعني تصل فيها مناطيت
صينيه الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن
هذه اول مره ينزل الى مستوى منخفض ويشاهده
الناس وهذا ما احرج الاداره الامريكيه
واضطرت الى يعني تطلق النار عليه وسبق
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان قامت
بالتجارب واطلقت يعني النار من صواريخ
1018 على منطاد
واسقطته لكن بقي سته ايام يعني الاجزاء
منه الغازات والاجهزه تنبعث لذلك كان خوف
القياده الامريكيه من ان اسقاطه قد يتسبب
في اضرار وهذا سيؤذن اكثر العلاقات بين
الصين وبين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لذلك انتظروا حتى يصل فوق البحر ويقع هناك
وبالتالي يستطيعون ان ياخذوا الحيطان من
البحر على العموم حنشوف ايش راح يصير كمان
في الايام الجايه بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور احمد عجاج شكرا لك